[موسيقى]
مليون صح بيسو غلطه واحده
بس مليون غلطه ما بيتعودوا بصاح واحد
سكتت هلا لست ثواني من عبارات وشكون عم
بستنتج انه ما فهمته ليش بس
فكرتو
غلط ليه غلط انه الواحد يسكت ست ثواني
بالكلمه وكلمه
جواب الوحيد اللي معقول يصلي هو انه
تعودنا هيك
فكرته انه الشيء اللي عملته غلط وهيدا
الشي مش الحق عليكم
من زمان كتير في ناس
اجتماعيه من وقتها تعود الانسان على
التصنيف بين الصح والغلط والناس معودين
على هذا الشي مشان هيك فكرتوا انه الغلط
الواحد يسكت ست ثواني
صح وبالنسبه لالك غلط فيكم شي بالنسبه
لالك صح شي بالنسبه لالي غلط
من احنا وصغار معودين على جوابين اللي هن
صح او غلط بس ليه ما في جواب تالت بيقول
مختلف
من زمان كتير في ناس ما السلطه والقوه
قررتها سندا على هول الاوانين تعودنا على
التصنيف بين الصح والغلط
على سيره السلطه
او الكون التاريخ صح او الكون التاريخ
دقيق او الكل مزبوط رح اقول لكم شو
التاريخ تاريخ هو
القصه الخبر التاريخي اللي اصحاب السلطه
بدهم تعرفوها القصه لاصحاب السلطه بدهم
تستمر بكتب التاريخ بس لكل خبر تاريخي
بتلاقي مليون صياغه له مثلا الحرب بين
الولايات الانجليزيه بامريكا وبين
الانجليز يلي اديت لتاسيس الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الانجليز حيخبروها
بطريقه
تانيه او مثلا حابب بين تركيا وارمينيا
الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا هيدا مثل على
انه بالنسبه لكل بلد كان الي عم يعملوا صح
واللي البلد الاخر عم بيعمله غلط لكن هون
ما عم نحكي عن شي صح ما عم نحكي عن شيء
غلط عم نحكي عن شي مختلف
من جهه تانيه شو هو مفهوم الغرض الغلط هو
لما شخص يوقف بوجهه القوانين الاجتماعيه
ويخالفهم
في سؤال بيطرح نفسه ليش نحن بنخاف من فكره
الغلط
منفخاف من فكره الغلط لانه الغلط اثقل من
الصح متل ما ذكرت سابقا مليون غلط ما
بيتعودوا بصاح واحد بس مليون صح بينتزعوا
بغلطه واحده
في واحد من لعيبه المفضل بالفوتبول اسمه
كان حارس مرمى وقال حارس المرمى بشيل بشيل
ميه جول بالماتش بس الكل حيتذكر يقول واحد
اللي اكله
في كمان دراسه من بلوكس سوسيال بتقول انه
انه 35% من الزباين بامريكا
بينزلوا تعليق سلبي على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
وثلاثه وخمسين بالميه بنزلوا تعليق ايجابي
وبالرغم من هذا الشيء مع انه التعليق
السلبي هو الاقل نسبيا بينقرع بنسبه 63%
اكثر من التعليم ايجابي
هلا يمكن عم تسالوا حالكم انا شخصني بكل
هذا الشيء رح اقول لكم اكثر شي بتشوف فيه
بحياه الصح والغلط هو التربايه ان كان اسد
زتنا معلميننا اهلنا كلنا مسؤولين عن
تربيتنا
للماضي
وما بيجربوا
غلط
رح ناخد سوا حالتين
في ام
خايفه على ابنها لكن بدها تجيب له
التليفون على عمر العشر سنين كرمال تاجر
تتابعوا كرمال اجري يتعود على عصر
التكنولوجيا
كمان خايفه على ابنها بس ما بدها تجيب له
تليفون قبل 13 سنه ليش لانه ما بدها اياه
ويمكن يدور له ويمكن يتعرض لقصص بهذا
الحال في حدا صح في حدا غلط في حدا معه حق
الاثنين خايفين على ابنهم والهدف هو ذاته
الولد راح يحصل على تليفون بس طريقه
الوصول للهدف تغيرت
لكن هون كمان ما عم نحكي عن شي صح وما عم
نحكي عن شيء غلط عم نحكي عن شي مختلف
لازم نقبل ان الزمن تغير وبعد رح يتغير
كتير وبدنا بنرده لورا خلينا نقبل ان
الزمن تغير ونجرب نطوره قد ما فينا ونعيش
ونعيش اللحظه كرمال نقدر نستفيد منها على
الاخر ما نضل نجرب
صح والغلط هو مش اكتر من وهم وهم اخترعوه
كرمال دايما تفكر انه انه بدك موافقه حدا
او موافقه فكره كرمال تمشي بقناعاتك
هلا راح لخيس كل شي قلته بفكره واحده
يعني قاعد هالميله رح يقرا كلمه يمين ويلي
قاعد هالميله رح يرى كلمه شمال انا ماسك
شغله واحده بس رح يقولوها بطريقه مختلفه
حسب من وين شايفينها
قد ما تقنعوا بعض انه هيدي هي الكلمه
وقدمها هيدا النص يقطع يقنع تاني نص انه
هيدي هي الكلمه رح يضل شايف هذا الكلمه
لانه لانه هو هيك اوريو يعني بهذه الحال
ما في حدا صح وما في حدا غلط في حدا مختلف
اذا بنرجع شوي لاسم الايفنت
مين قال انه الضو دائما هو الصح ومين قال
انه العتم دائما هو الغلط
لكن اذا بدكم تتذكروا اياه اليوم
انا بدل صني بين الصح والغلط صرت اقبل
لانه في شي مختلف ومش يعني ضروري هو غلط
وانا بدل ما اخاف انا بد ما اخاف استكشف
لانه معقول فكرتي تكون غلط صرت تحب وانا
بدل ما
وانا بدل ما اخاف بدل ما اخاف من انه
الناس فاكره انه فكرتي غلط وبدل ما خاف
اشتغل على انا عاطي لانه معقول الباقي ما
يقتنها اشتغل على قناعاتي ولما يشوفوا قد
ايه
يقتنعوا
بطلت تخاف انه يفكرتي غلط لانه وين ما رحت
إذا انرفضت فكرتي بمحال رح تنقبل بمحل
ثاني لانه وين ما كان بيختلف الصح من
الغلط
[تصفيق]